530 million miles from the sun, a tiny lump
of ice and rock starts its journey towards
the inner solar system.
Scientifically, comets are more precious than
pure gold.
They are actual time capsules.
They are preservations of what the
chemistry, the environment was like when our
solar system formed.
And they hold clues as to how our chemistry
arrived here on Earth.
Comets are some of the most valuable
scientific treasures that exist.
Finding a comet we can study is not an easy
task.
Finding the right comet for a mission.
It's kind of like you're auditioning them,
right?
One comes in and it's like, Oh, that orbit's
okay, but it's not exactly what we're looking
for. And oh, this one's too big, this one's
too little, this one's too active.
What we really want to see is that comet come
from outer parts of the solar system and get
heated up as it gets close to the sun, pass
around the sun and head back out to the outer
part of the solar system. So you need to get
way out in the solar system and catch a comet
on its way in.
Comet £0.67 fits the bill.
The special thing about Comet £0.67 is how
accessible it is here on Earth.
It actually orbits around the sun once every
six and a half years, and its orbit doesn't
take it all that far out, only about as far
out as the planet Jupiter.
That gives us many chances to actually reach
the comet and successfully rendezvous with
it.
Holy mackerel.
67 PS moment in the spotlight arrived.
The European Space Agency launched the
groundbreaking Rosetta probe.
For years we've studied comets from afar.
We had never seen one up close with cutting
edge technology to learn about how comets
behave as they orbit the sun.
Missions to large planet sized objects are
hard.
The Hubble Space telescope's blurry images
revealed Rosetta's target is just two miles
wide. And not just a small target, a moving
one.
Comet £0.67 races through the solar system
at over 33,000 miles an hour.
The precision involved is pretty incredible.
It's like making that hole in one golf shot
from New York to San Francisco.
But catching Comet £0.67 wasn't just a
straight shot.
The spacecraft had to actually get the same
sort of velocity as the comet.
And with current propulsion systems, we
can't achieve that by flying directly to the
comet.
Instead, Rosetta performed a slingshot
maneuver that would take ten years.
That's what it's doing. It's actually taking
some energy away from the planet.
So it's slowing the planets down a little
bit and then imparting that energy into the
probe.
Rosetta flew past Jupiter nearly 100 million
miles from the warmth of the sun and entered
the most dangerous part of its journey.
Hibernation.
Even though Rosetta had solar panels on it,
it still had to be put to sleep.
And the reason for that is that it had to
track 60 7PA ways away from the sun and there
just was not enough collection area and
solar power to be able to power the
instruments.
There's no way to put spacecraft into
hibernation.
But the worrying thing at the back of your
mind is that it had never been done for this
long before.
31 months of hibernation gave Rosetta's team
plenty of time to worry about what could go
wrong.
It's dark and cold out there in space.
There's a lot of things going on.
There's a lot of little micrometeorites out
there.
And without the constant communication with
that spacecraft, just as a little nerve
wracking when the day comes and it's time to
flip the switch and turn it back.
On January 20th, 2014, after almost ten years
in space, it was finally time for Rosetta to
wake up, reactivate its communication system
and phone home.
I mean, the tension was just palpable.
It was just I mean, how long do we have to
wait before we're going to get the signal?
It's got to work. It has to work.
Oh gosh, maybe it's just not going to turn on
at all.
Have we lost the spacecraft?
And then the peak appeared on the graph.
It's like, yes, we've got contact with the
spacecraft.
Rosetta began to send back images of its
target and after months of seeing a small.in
the distance, the comet slowly came into
focus.
When I saw this comet crystal clear, this
mountain floating in space of ice and rock,
my heart just dropped.
There are some of the most dramatic,
beautiful images I have ever seen.
And then as it got closer and we got to see
more and more details on it, yeah, that's
when things started getting really strange.
Quite simply, arrival at £0.67.
We expected to see something shaped like a
potato and we found something shaped like a
rubber duck.
£0.67 is no ugly duckling, but its strange
shape created a problem for Rosetta.
Orbiting the comet was going to be far more
difficult than anyone had imagined.
A planet has a lot of gravity.
So you can send the spacecraft out there and
then just slow it down a little bit with a
rocket burn and it'll drop into orbit.
In the case of comet £0.67, you're dealing
with a very small little rock.
The spacecraft cannot feel the gravity of
that rock, at least not until it's right up
against it.
Well, the engineers had to actually plot
triangular orbits.
It was a very complicated set of maneuvers.
Once in orbit, Rosetta could start work.
Its first task Figure out how £0.67 formed.
So how did this comet get this weird shape?
There's two main ideas.
One is just that it was eroded somehow in
the center, and so it started off as a more
spherical thing and became the shape it is
today through some unknown process.
The other idea is that it started as two
separate objects.
Space rocks normally hit each other hard.
They collide with an average impact speed of
more than 11,000 miles an hour.
That's five times faster than a rifle
bullet.
Was £0.67 involved in a pile up.
A clue came from the distinct layers on the
comet's surface.
The layers in comet 67.
P are a little like the layers in an onion.
If you see them aligned, that's a clue that
perhaps the object formed as a single entity
and only eroded later into its present form.
But if you see those layers misaligned like
we actually do in the comet, that's a big
clue that it started out as two separate
objects formed independently, sticking
together to form the comet we see today.
The layers prove that £0.67 was originally
two separate objects that fused together.
The process of potentially putting Comet
£0.67 together from two different pieces is
important because it can teach us about what
was happening in the early solar system.
So as far as we can tell, these two separate
bodies must have been formed in the same
area. They're very similar in composition,
but they are so light and fluffy that they
would have destroyed each other if they had
hit fast.
They had a low speed collision and basically
stuck together like two wet snowballs.
With one mystery solved.
Rosetta began to investigate the chemical
makeup of £0.67.
The little Comet could answer one of the
biggest questions in planetary science from
where did our blue planet get its water?